S
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" FROM
WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
WE HAVE A TON TO GET TO, SO
LET'S DIVE RIGHT IN.
IT'S DO-OR-DIE IN THE SUBURBS.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
NOW, IT'S A MOMENT OF TRUTH FOR
ALL YOU MODERATES LIVING IN THE
SUBURBS.
NOW, MANY OF YOU, I KNOW, NOT
ALL, BUT MANY OF YOU VOTED
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP BY VOTING
FOR BIDEN AND AT THE TIME I
THINK YOU FELT GOOD ABOUT IT,
VIRTUOUS EVEN.
ESPECIALLY YOU SUBURBAN WOMEN.
YOU'RE THE BIGGEST VOTING
COHORT, MAKING 20% OF THE VOTING
IN 2020?
AND YOU WENT 59% FOR BIDEN AND
ONLY 40% FOR TRUMP.
WELL, YOU FELT GOOD ABOUT
YOURSELVES AT THE TIME, BUT WHAT
ABOUT NOW?
THE EVENTS OF THE LAST YEAR, AND
ESPECIALLY THE PAST SIX MONTHS
DEMONSTRATE THAT YOU'VE GOT A
LOT MORE TROUBLE THAN YOU
BARGAINED FOR.
THE FACT IS, THERE ARE NO MORE
MODERATES LEFT IN THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY TO REIGN IN THE RADICALS
AND AS I WARNED -- I THINK IT
WAS EXACTLY ALMOST A YEAR AGO.
BIDEN IS TOO WEAK TO STAND UP TO
THE HARD LEFT.
A MESSAGE TO SUBURBAN WOMEN AND
OLDER VOTERS, BIDEN IS NOT GOING
TO DELIVER THE CALM THAT YOU
THINK YOU MIGHT.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BECOME THE
PARTY OF CHAOS, LAWLESSNESS, AND
DISORDER.
AND WHEN THEY CAN'T GET THEIR
WAY THROUGH VOTING, THEY'LL
ENCOURAGE RIOTING AND LOOTING.
AND IF YOU RESIST OR YOU DON'T
PUBLICLY PROFESS YOUR WHITE
GUILT, THEY WILL DESTROY YOU.
THEY HATE OUR HISTORY, OUR
TRADITIONS, AND OUR WAY OF LIFE.
>> Laura: NOT TO MENTION THAT
BIDEN'S LACKEYS WANT TO WIPE THE
SUBURBS OFF THE MAP.
LIKE EVERY THING ELSE, THEY SEE
THE SUBURBS AS THEMSELVES
INHERENTLY RACIST.
KIND OF THE SIGN OF DECADENT
WHITE PRIVILEGE BUILT ON THE
BACKS OF MINORITY SUFFERING.
AS WE'VE WARNED YOU, THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL CAJOLE
LOCALITIES INTO ELIMINATING
SO-CALLED EXCLUSIONARY ZONING
LAWS THAT MAKE THE SUBURBS
POSSIBLE.
GOODBYE, PICKET FENCE HOUSES,
HELLO, HIGH-RISES AND MULTI-USE
LIVING AND OF COURSE THE RAMPANT
CRIME THAT CAN COME ALONG WITH
IT.
SPEAKING OF WHICH, BIDEN'S
ANSWER TO THE TERRIFYING SPIRAL
OF CRIME THAT IS SWEEPING ACROSS
THE COUNTRY SHOULD ITSELF BE A
WAKE-UP CALL TO ALL YOU
SUBURBANITES THAT VOTED FOR HIM.
HIS STUPID GUN-CONTROL SPEECH
TODAY JUST CONFIRMS WHAT WE
NOTED LAST NIGHT, THAT DEMOCRATS
DEFIANTLY REFUSE TO DO WHAT WE
ALL KNOW WORKS TO REDUCE CRIME.
AND THEY'RE DOING THAT IN FAVOR
OF EMPTY, SYMBOLIC GESTURES THAT
SATISFY THEIR RABID
ANTI-SECOND AMENDMENT BASE.
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON AND WITH
THE HELP OF
THEN-SENATOR JOE BIDEN AND
REPUBLICANS, REMEMBER, THEY ALL
TACKLED RISING CRIME IN THE
1990s.
DID A GOOD JOB OF IT.
BUT NOW THAT THE HARD LEFT IS IN
CHARGE, THEY ARE SIMPLY NEVER
GOING TO CRACKDOWN ON CRIME.
THEY JUST MOUTH PLATITUDES ABOUT
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND THEN
THEY SHOVEL TAXPAYER MONEY OUT
THE DOOR TO THEIR CRONIES.
>> THIS IS NOT DEFUNDING OUR
COMMUNITIES, IT'S INVESTING IN
THEM FOR CRIME PREVENTION AND
FOR COMMUNITY BUILDING AND
SOCIAL SERVICES.
>> FOSTERING TRUST AND EARNING
LEGITIMACY IN OUR COMMUNITIES --
>> WE KNOW SUMMER JOB TRAINING,
SUMMER JOBS TRAINING AND
RECREATION FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
WORK.
THEY HELP MAKE SURE YOUNG PEOPLE
PICK UP THE PAYCHECK INSTEAD OF
A PISTOL.
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO DO ON THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT SIDE, OCCLUDING,
BY THE WAY, ADDRESSING THE RISE
IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE EXTREMISM.
>> Laura: YOU CAN ALWAYS COUNT
ON MAISIE FOR REAL WISDOM.
MEANWHILE, THE BODIES CONTINUE
TO PILE UP AS CRIME SKYROCKETS,
TAKING NOT JUST BLACK LIVES, BUT
BLUE LIVES AS WELL.
ON MONDAY, 19 YOUR COLORADO
POLICE FORCE VETERAN GORDON
BEASLEY WAS AMBUSHED IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT, SHOT AND KILLED.
TODAY WE LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
SUSPECT'S MOTIVE.
>> I CAN TELL YOU THAT GORDON
WAS TARGETED BECAUSE HE WAS
WEARING A NEVADA POLICE UNIFORM
AND A BADGE.
OFFICER BEASLEY WAS AMBUSHED BY
A PERSON WHO EXPRESSED HATRED OF
POLICE OFFICERS.
>> Laura: I WONDER WHERE THAT
HATRED WAS FED FROM.
MONDAY WAS ALSO ONE OF CHICAGO'S
BLOODIEST DAYS YET DURING THE
CURRENT CRIME WAVE.
SEVEN KILLS, 11 WOUNDED.
YESTERDAY, ONE MORE WAS KILLED
WITH FIVE WOUNDED BY GUNFIRE
INCLUDING A 15-YEAR-OLD BOY SHOT
IN A DRIVE-BY.
IF ALL THE DEPRESSING HEADLINES
ABOUT INNER-CITY AMERICA IN THE
PAST FEW DAYS, I FOUND ONE
PARTICULARLY DISTURBING.
57 DEAD IN 50 DAYS AS VIOLENCE
CONTINUES TO RAVAGE BALTIMORE
CITY.
TODAY THESE TWO MEN, CHRISTIAN
ST. ROSE, AND JAMAAL KINGSBORO,
WERE ARRESTED FOR THE SHOCKING
MIDDAY EXECUTION OF 34-YEAR-OLD
TONY.
AT NO PROTEST, NO MARCHES, NO
CELEBRITY DEMANDS FOR JUSTICE
FOR THESE VICTIMS.
AND IF YOU REFUSE TO SUBMIT TO
WHAT THEIR THOUGHT PROCESS IS
ABOUT WHY CRIME IS EXPLODING,
WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO DO?
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO RUN YOU
OVER.
JUST LIKE THEY DID TO THOSE
PARENTS IN LOUDOUN COUNTY,
VIRGINIA, LAST NIGHT.
[BOOS]
>> [INDISCERNIBLE].
>> COWARD!
>> Laura: I KNOW ANOTHER PLACE
WHERE THEY TAKE A SIMILAR
APPROACH TO DISSENTING VIEWS.
I THINK WHEN YOU REALLY THINK
ABOUT IT, CHINA ACTUALLY HAS TO
LOVE CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
IN FACT, THEY HUMILIATED BIDEN'S
SECRETARY OF STATE IN ALASKA
LAST MONTH WHEN CHINA ENDED UP
PARROTING BACK TO HIM THE
DEMOCRATS GO TO LINES ABOUT
AMERICA'S PROBLEM WITH SYSTEMIC
RACISM.
SO THEY WERE ALL PROBABLY ELATED
OVER THERE IN BEIJING TO HEAR
THAT BIDEN'S CHAIRMAN OF THE
JOINT CHIEF DEFENDED IT ON
CAPITOL HILL TODAY.
>> FIRST OF ALL, ON THE ISSUE OF
CRITICAL RACE THEORY, ET CETERA.
I DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT,
ACTUALLY, FOR THOSE OF US IN
UNIFORM TO BE OPEN MINDED AND TO
BE WIDELY READ.
I WANT TO UNDERSTAND WHITE RAGE
AND I'M WHITE.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
UNDERSTAND IT BECAUSE THEY COME
FROM THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THAT
MATTERS TO OUR MILITARY AND THE
DISCIPLINE AND THE COHESION OF
THIS MILITARY.
>> Laura: WHAT PAUL --
[INDISCERNIBLE] SERVE.
SOMEHOW I DON'T THINK
GENERAL MILLEY WOULD EVER SPEAK
IN THIS DISMISSIVE TONE THAT HE
TOOK TODAY TO HIS CHINESE
COUNTERPARTS.
NOT THE WAY HE SPOKE TO
CONGRESSMAN WALL.
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
GENERAL.
WHY WOULD ANYONE RISK HIS OR HER
LIFE FOR A COUNTRY THAT IS
SYSTEMICALLY RACIST?
ONE THAT BRUTALIZE AS
MINORITIES.
WHY WOULD ANY COUNTRY RESPECT US
OR FOLLOW OUR LEAD IF THAT'S WHO
WE ARE?
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
HE SHOULD PROBABLY THINK ABOUT
BEFORE HE TOUTS THE VALUE OF
TEACHING FAR LEFT MARXIST RACIST
IDEOLOGY TO OUR TROOPS.
THE FACT IS, MILLIE HAS MADE HIS
CHOICE IF HE'S CHOSEN TO INDULGE
THE RADICAL WHIMS OF DEMOCRATS.
HE'LL DO EVERYTHING THEY TELL
HIM AS LONG AS THEY KEEP THE
MILITARY INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX
FLUSH WITH CASH.
BUT IS ANY OF THIS WHAT MOTHERS
AND FATHERS IN THE SUBURBS
THOUGHT THEY WERE GETTING WHEN
THEY VOTED FOR SWEET OLD
JOE BIDEN?
THINK ABOUT ALL OF THIS.
IF YOU WORKED HARD TRYING TO
RAISE A FAMILY, IF YOU PAID YOUR
TAXES, YOU'RE A GOOD CITIZEN.
YOU HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO EXPECT
THAT WHERE YOU LIVE WILL BE SAFE
AND CLEAN, THAT YOUR SCHOOLS
WILL BE FUNCTIONAL THEY WILL
TEACH YOUR KIDS ON INFORMED
PATRIOTISM AND PREPARE CHILDREN
FOR THE CHALLENGING WORLD AHEAD.
I MEAN, THIS SHOULD BE THE CASE
MATTER WHERE YOU LIVE IN A
COUNTRY LIKE THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA, WHETHER YOU ARE IN A
CITY OR THE COUNTRY, RURAL
AMERICA.
YOU KNOW, THINK ABOUT IT.
IN URBAN AMERICA, THE MIDDLE
CLASS RIGHT NOW IS FLEEING AS
SOON AS IT CAN BECAUSE LIBERAL
LEADERSHIP HAS DRIVEN IT ALL
INTO THE GUTTER IN THE CITY.
BUT THE HARD LEFT, THEY'RE FINE
WITH THE URBAN AMERICA THIS WAY.
BUT I THINK THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY WANTS TO LIVE THAT WAY.
MOST REPUBLICAN-RUN STATES OUR
BLUEPRINTS FOR BETTER, MORE
PROSPEROUS AND SAFER LIVING
TODAY.
BUT TRY TO IMAGINE WHAT OUR
COUNTRY IS GOING TO LOOK LIKE IF
THE FAR LEFT IS ALLOWED TO GET
AWAY WITH TEACHING AN ENTIRE
GENERATION OR TWO OR THREE TO
DESPISE OUR COUNTRY AND ITS
FOUNDING.
TO VIEW THE TRADITIONS WE GREW
UP LOVING FROM SINGING THE
STAR-SPANGLED BANNER AT A
BASEBALL GAME, TO FLYING A FLAG.
CONSIDER THOSE THINGS LIKE
RACIST DOG WHISTLES?
PLUS, LETS HER MEMBER, MANY OF
YOUR SUBURBANITES EITHER RUN
SUCCESSFUL BUSINESSES, OR YOU
WORK AT ONE.
YOU MAY FEEL INSULATED, I KNOW,
FROM THE MADNESS AROUND YOU.
BUT IF YOU THINK THAT, YOU'RE
SORELY MISTAKEN.
NO ONE IS SAFE IN THEIR LAND OF
THOUGHT CONTROL.
JUST IN THE PAST MONTH, EVERYONE
FROM A LIBERAL PLAYWRIGHT, WHEN
MEN WILL MIRANDA TO SINGER BILLY
EYELASH
HAS FELT THE NEED TO APOLOGIZE
FOR THERE IS SUPPOSE IT UNWOKISM
AND THINGS WENT TO A NEW LEVEL
OF THE ABSURD WHEN 89-YEAR-OLD
LEGEND RITA MORENO HAD TO
APOLOGIZE FOR DISMISSING THE
COLOR ISM ATTACKS AGAINST
MR. MIRANDA.
THE POINT IS, IF THOSE BELOVED
CELEBRITIES AREN'T SAFE FROM
THESE VICIOUS TAKEDOWN MOBS, WHY
WAS YOUR AVERAGE SUBURBAN MOTHER
WITHOUT ANY POWER CELEBRITY
STATUS THINK SHALL BE SAFE?
THEY THINK PUTTING UP
BLM-APPROVED YARD SIGNS OR
TRENDY FLAGS ARE GOING TO
PROTECT THEM?
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO PROTECT
THEM!
THEY THINK GIVING MONEY TO
DEMOCRATS OR BLACK LIVES
MATTER-AFFILIATED GROUPS IS
GOING TO SAVE THEM?
IT WON'T SAVE THEM.
IF THE CANCER CULTURE DOESN'T
GET YOU, THE RACIAL DIVISION
SQUADS IN THE SCHOOLS WILL GET
YOUR KIDS AND THEN THEY'RE GOING
TO TURN YOUR KIDS AGAINST YOU.
AND THEN CRIME IS GOING TO START
SEEPING INTO YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD
JUST IN TIME FOR YOU TO SEE THE
COST OF EVERYTHING GO UP AND OF
COURSE THAT MEANS YOUR PAYCHECK
WON'T GO AS FAR.
DO